after the first trailer for the batman
introduced us to the newest version of
bruce wayne played by robert pattinson
the second trailer has followed it up to
give us an even better look at the
upcoming superhero flick which will
release exclusively in theaters on march
4th
the second trailer continues with the
epic scope established by the first
while diving more into the dark cd plot
the riddler is on a killing spree
targeting the elite of gotham but it's
clear from the way bruce wayne is
targeted that there's more going on here
than meets the eye it's easy to overlook
certain details among all of the action
and the budding romance between bruce
and zoe kravitz's selena kyle some of
them may prove to be more important than
others once the film finally comes out
but for now here are some extra details
you may want to give a second look
during your trailer re-watch at one
point in the trailer the riddler
seemingly taunts batman assuring him
that he plays an integral role in his
reign of carnage but when batman asks
what role that is riddler responds
oh you're really not as smart as i
thought you were
bruce
wayne
granted this could be a result of some
clever audio editing but it does sound
as if riddler knows that batman is bruce
wayne this would fit in well with the
comics and the story line for hush
riddler is one of the few villains in
gotham to know batman's secret identity
the batman trailer also suggests bruce
wayne will have a dark night of the soul
when revelations come to light the
trailer depicts bruce and alfred having
a heated conversation about alfred's
years-long deception given how riddler
appears to be targeting gotham's elite
class it would make the most sense for
alfred's secret to somehow factor into
bruce's parents there's no shortage of
clandestine organizations in the comics
that seek to make the city a more
profitable space and the most likely
culprit for the organization related to
mr and mrs wayne would be the court of
owls that agency was hinted at in the
first teaser and there are definitely
enough clues in the recent footage to
suggest they could factor into the plot
somehow then again it's always possible
the court of owls will remain on the
sidelines to be used for a possible
sequel to the batman by night bruce
wayne gives back to gotham as its dark
protector batman but by day bruce wayne
normally gives back to the city in other
ways from the comics to cartoons bruce
wayne has been a philanthropist often
hosting charity drives to give back to
the city batman may be an immediate fix
to clean up the streets but bruce wayne
aims to invest in long-term solutions to
protect the city it's the latter
identity that's seemingly fallen by the
wayside at least according to the latest
trailer for the batman mayoral candidate
bella rial tells bruce you know you
really could be doing more for this city
my family has a history of philanthropy
but as far as i can tell you're not
doing anything
it's in stark contrast to the bruce
wayne audiences usually know but it
could all be a setup this is still a
young version of bruce wayne we're
seeing who's only been batman for a
relatively short period of time it makes
sense given the story will draw
influence from batman year one so bruce
is still obviously trying to get a
handle on balancing his public and
private personas the marketing materials
for the batman so far have given us good
looks at most of the main cast but paul
dayno who plays riddler hasn't been
shown a great deal there are plenty of
shots of him unravelling a roll of duct
tape and speaking ominously but he's
always shown with something over his
face even in the scene in the diner that
presumably features riddler unmasked
getting arrested his face is blocked
from view is there more to riddler than
meets the eye seeing how this version of
the riddler takes some obvious cues from
real life serial killer the zodiac
perhaps it makes sense for riddler to
have an air of mystery around him too
there's still much we don't know about
the upcoming the batman and that's just
the way many fans would like it all will
be revealed when the movie comes out on
march 4th 2022
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]